liam was the one turning the screw
putting the pressure on so i think he's
definitely a favorite in this one with
white but
jordan super good uh super fast super
tricky okay the game has started and
it's the sloth opening it's almost too
quick there to explain but black has
gone and grabbed a pawn so in similar
vein to the queen's gambit black grabbed
a pawn but that pawn has been won back
and
this is actually one of my favorite
openings as well um and okay this last
move the white queen move i must admit
i've never seen that one before normally
the white queen goes to a different
square jordan he's been a specialist in
this since 2015 2016. i remember
studying his games when he was just
young uh in this opening so
yeah very tense at this early stage
black just bringing out pieces white
with a bit more space in the center yeah
i mean we could see the isolated pawn
position if black decides to take in the
middle of the board and white captures
back with a pawn
this is something we've seen often
but nope we're going for a more
symmetrical structure meaning armageddon
is happening definitely we want
armageddon oh yeah we haven't seen it so
far this season yeah i better be careful
saying that with the world politics
actually but yeah just stick to the
chessboard it's depressing but anyway
yeah back to the chest he's bringing his
bishop out to a better square maybe
slightly better for white here um but
it's so symmetrical at this level these
nearly always
uh peter out don't they somewhat i don't
know i always feel that white has that
slight edge you know just kind of on the
base is that it's easier to connect the
rooks it's easier to centralize and you
have of course
that extra move that you get from
starting the game first and this is the
kind of idea that i had in mind
okay so a set of pieces have been traded
and suddenly look at the white bishops
especially the white dark square bishop
back there on the b2 square it's
pointing towards the black king white's
queen is edging towards the black king
as well
i would choose white here oh definitely
i mean i think maybe black fought he
could push the f pawn here which should
be a way to uh kick things back but you
can never push that pawn uh because of
the pin so he's going for more exchanges
get the rooks off the board and try to
ease your problems
big threat white queen is trying to zoom
up to the g7 square the pawn in front of
the black king take it and that would
actually be checkmate immediately
because the white bishop on the b2
square helping it out teaming up now
lots of pieces heading towards that
black king i don't like what jordan's
done and he's about to push a pawn in
front of the black king he has to but
it's going to weaken squares and look at
those dark squares around the black king
now ripe for a white piece if white's
knight can just pick itself up and plant
it on one of those dark squares around
black's king
game over it'd actually be incredible if
we don't have any armageddons in the
whole tournament i mean uh you'd expect
at least one from over the over the
games we've had so far but white has a
big initiative now i mean i'd be
thinking about throwing the knight
towards the black king just trying to
start an attack against that king which
has weakened itself by moving a pawn in
front of it maybe you could push old
harry boy yeah you know up the board
just do a little bit of nibbling over
there nibble away i like it he's throwed
the knight in yeah i love that kind of
move because there's a big threat of
actually moving the knight to the center
and this has a prompted jordan to
desperately push his pawn forward
attacking the queen but this is so
weakening
it's so ugly for black yeah
all those dark squares around the black
king oh it looks it's beginning to look
a little bit terminal i have to say what
is jordan doing here just he's just
playing move by move i think he's just
trying to survive the next uh
whatever happens next but long term he's
weakened himself look at that black king
how many holes around it i mean if you
could remove the white knight from the
board just imagine getting that knight
off the board um let's say e5 i just
want to show one idea e5 looks like we
just bring up the analysis very quickly
an idea to block out the black bishop so
you can see white's bishop the knight
comes back and now black carefully well
the queen has this lovely idea which uh
which comes in now using a pin um maybe
we just showed that
check and the black pawn cannot
recapture the queen because this
platform is actually pinned along the
diagonal um so just watch out for these
two white bishops and actually what's
happened on the board is very
instructive on the last turn jordan was
saying please trade rooks please swap
off the rooks any uh trades will
actually favor the defending side but of
course liam says no no trades i'm trying
to attack and this black king it's all
about this diagonal right now as simon
said if you push your pawn and block
this diagonal suddenly the other
diagonal becomes open and uh it just
looks so scary white has a massive
threat in the position if black just
makes a move white tonight is coming
back and then it's all about this square
the knight and bishop are going to team
up to just infiltrate and crash through
towards the black king this is the
threat in the current position white's
knight coming back you can't stop it it
just looks beautiful for white this
position it's all about the white
bishops
yeah i mean i can't even suggest a good
move for black actually i mean the only
thing i was thinking was maybe attack
the queen but that's just
a kind of a spike move you know i have
no plan drop the bishop back attack the
white queen yeah but white pawns might
even start running forward i really like
what liam's done look how calm he is as
well and we're going to see this happen
the white queen attacked by a black
bishop and blocked straight away
straight away the pawn comes up and you
know what that pawn could even move
again later on bringing in more
firepower um jordan's trying everything
but liam keeping he's no way he's gonna
exchange that bishop off that bishop is
so dangerous and now you can't stop the
knight coming back there's nothing you
can do to stop that night going to the
square david mentioned it's almost game
over i mean how would you defend you
have no useful productive moves here as
black um
all of white's pieces look at them
they're all pointed towards the black
king white's light square bishop white's
dark square bishop white's queen
all teamed up and black's king has zero
defenders around it if you had a black
knight near the king maybe you could
survive but you can't survive an attack
if you have no defensive pieces simple
as that i was kind of thinking you know
maybe the black king could kind of go on
a desperate run
where's it going
but that was the issue if there were too
many pieces in its way i was like maybe
it could run away to the left but um
maybe jordan can sneeze take the king
off the wooden board and move it to the
other side of the table yeah but
actually it's online online so you can't
even cheat which is very unfortunate i
mean this is i don't think he can
survive this also guys not is it not
only is this position hopeless but look
at the clock time one minute 40 against
more than four minutes there's no chance
jordan saving this game this game has
just been a master class from liam in
how to attack how to build up an attack
very naturally very smoothly actually
the only thing okay let's uh can black
just throw a piece forward you know
i don't know maybe attack the bishop
there you go throwing a piece forward
to the fourth he's gone backwards
he's trying to defend i mean he's got to
cover that weak and square so it's
actually a very imaginative way to try
and defend but uh is so passive putting
the knight there and i you know we could
even see this f pawn joining in at some
point i feel let's say the night goes
back uh we can analyze this quickly
there's a little forced variation so the
knight comes to try and get into the
weak and square of a big check jordan's
idea is to cover that square by moving
his knight so his knight comes out and
now something like another pawn joins in
he's done it straight away straight away
breaking through
yeah trying to open up all the bishops
all the queens all the rooks everything
yeah so he's done it in this position
pushed his pawn forward and okay this
has allowed meanwhile the black bishop
to retreat hitting the white queen and
now
okay i just peeked at the computer
is there something sacrifices queen and
win oh
he's done it wow beautiful he's given up
his queen so the bishop's about to take
the queen but he just plays pawn takes
pawn ignoring it now the queen when it
disappears pawn takes pawn and this king
is doomed the white bishop
i mean this is one of the games of the
tournament and he saved it till the end
yeah the bishops crashed through the
white rook of protecting this pawn i
mean this is just gonna end the game the
bishop can capture but you just take
back and black is forced to give back
the queen white will emerge with extra
pawns in the end game even after that
sacrifice
and uh white is winning
wow
that's incredible lovely
beautiful finish to the tournaments yeah
queen sacrifice that is like the crown
jewel yeah when you play chess it's what
you want to do
you want to have it in your best game
collection you didn't even stop to think
liam he sacrificed the queen and uh he
barely paused and okay you're doing
desperate now just pushed the pawn
forward but this pawn could be captured
by the white bishop did he forget about
that bishop at the bottom of the board
it was hopeless anyway and look at that
evaluation bar realising it's completely
winning for white the black king is
doomed
yeah and i think he's about to resign
he's got his headphones yeah he's had
enough though
it's over that is the final game in the
oslo esports cup a
beautiful win in the blitz tie breaks by
liam leah to take
second place in the tournament they're
standing there and do you think that is
what they're talking about now that
possible
queen sacrifice yeah maybe jordan's just
saying well done that was nice you
sometimes you just have to appreciate
beautiful moves beautiful concepts and
ideas but yeah jordan will be okay i was
gonna say he will be gutted because he
had chances to win this match but no a
nice touch there the players smiling and
having a laugh together